tafer jebali bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le voit à la colère ne retombe pas aux
états unis avec ces manifestations un
petit peu partout suite au décès de
georges floyd en quoi justement la
disparition de cet afro américain est-il
emblématique
je dirais tout d'abord c'est un drame de
plus ce n'est pas nouveau dans
l'histoire des états unis de voir des
voir des noirs américains victimes du
racisme à la fois de de quelques blancs
racistes et biologiquement et de la
police donc ce qui est choquant dans ce
dernier drame d'ailleurs c'est en quinze
jours je crois aux trois semaines on a
vu deux
celui d'un marteau d'un joggeur blanc a
mouse henry qui faisait du jogging dans
un quartier blanc il été victime d'une
embuscade par des blancs racistes
certainement et là on a vu une scène
avec ce jardin fleuri d' incroyable
inadmissible insupportable c'est que
c'est presque il ya un côté filmique
théâtrale presque tellement on ne
croyait pas ce qu'on voyait donc c'est
choquant c'est un drame de plus la
population noire est victime d'actes
violents de la part des racistes de la
part de la police
et là la réaction pas uniquement des
noirs des faut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
blancs qui s'opposent à ces pratiques à
ce racisme latent qui touche la police
et là évidemment c'est l'embrasement
mais on a vu déjà dans l'histoire
américaine justement qu'est-ce qui
explique cette succession de bavures
policières est ce une montée du racisme
ou est ce que finalement la police
n'est pas assez formés sur le terrain
tout d'abord chaque citoyen est
pratiquement un journaliste aujourd'hui
chez ans au bal à tous avec notre
smartphone donc c'est aussi le fait
qu'on on est capable aujourd'hui de
filmer des scènes qui arrive est très
souvent auparavant mais qui passait
inaperçu parce que la police très
souvent couvre ces actes barbares et ses
actes violents donc cette fois ci et
bien sûr il y à il ya l'entraînement de
la police la société américaine est une
société violente
c'est dans sa nature je dirais même que
elle est fondée sur la violence
le péché originel c'est l'extermination
des indiens
l'esclavagé est un acte violent donc le
lynchage de plus de 3000 noir entre je
crois 1880 et 1868
donc c'est pour vous dire que ce n'est
pas nouveau c'est la police certainement
et mal entraînés mais parmi la police
il ya certainement des red necks des
racistes qui de trouvera l'occasion pour
passer à l'acte
comment mettre fin à ces violences est
ce qu'il y a une part de responsabilité
de la part du gouvernement c'est que un
des policiers qui est responsable
justement de la mort de joe wright a été
inculpé qu'est ce qu'il risque
finalement est-ce que cela va suffire
tout d'abord il a fallu quatre cinq
jours de violences d'embrasement pour
que la justice bouge
le premier acte qui est qu'ils n'étaient
pas à la hauteur de ce meurtre
inadmissible c'est et de virer le
policier ou les quatre policiers qui
étaient appliquées ce n'était pas
suffisant de la vie des parents de la
vie du monde entier tous ceux qui ont vu
la vidéo trouvé ça choquant donc
maintenant après la pression de la rue
c'est la justice qui bouge
donc il ya certainement une complicité
judiciaire il ya une complicité
policière
dans le système américain donc
maintenant qu'est ce qu'ils risquent il
reste que ça sur le plan juridique entre
10 et 25 ans parce que il est inculpé
pour une mare son intention de la donner
et ainsi de suite donc ce n'est
certainement pas le dernier
bang ce n'est pas le dernier martres
malheureusement il y aura d'autres lui
l'art a d'autres qui passeront inaperçus
parce que il ya personne qui filme
autour et léonard a d'autres qui vont
être médiatisé et donc ils vont susciter
l'indignation générale mais quelque part
c'est en est dans la continuité de cette
violence qui gangrène la société
américaine et je dérive depuis le
premier jour de la formation de cette
société merci beaucoup et infect dis ben
ali d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université de caen